is now a good time to invest in property
the media will tell you no the TV will
tell you no the banks will tell you no
the banks will say now is not a good
time to invest in property it's very
risky but what are the banks doing
investing in property what are the
people that own the media channels doing
investing in property huh are we being
tricked the answer is yes in fact right
now I believe is probably the best
opportunity to invest in property and
I've been in property fulltime for 15
years you know when the second best time
was around about 2009 I bought my first
house in 2009 and the media was saying
now's a terrible time houses are
crashing but I bought anyway and you
know what happens after a crash always
comes a boom right now in 2023 what have
we seen we've seen interest rates
soaring high we've seen house prices
falling and we've seen the media and
everybody trying to say that investing
in property is bad we've had the EPC
changes where the government have
announced oh from now on you have to
have an energy performance certificate
of C you know come 2025 and everyone's
scared ah and they're selling who they
selling to the rich people the same
people that create the rules in property
we've heard tenant eviction bans section
21 are going to be abolished scrapped
everyone's scared oh my gosh tention BS
EBC they will say do you know what
they've done the last few weeks they've
undone all of those changes that they
were going to bring in section 21 that
was going to be scrapped the government
have just said we're not going to scrap
it after all actually it's just going to
stay exactly as it was so all the people
that sold their houses because they were
scared about the tenant eviction ban
section 21 being scrapped how they
feeling now oh man I sold my house
because of the new changes which never
came in oh I sold my house because of
the energy performance certificate you
know what they said they said the energy
performance certificate every house that
you rent out has an energy performance
certificate the energy performance
certificate should be a c if it's a d or
an e that's okay but any higher than an
e that means the house is not energy
efficient enough and you can't rent the
house out at the moment and E is the max
they said they were going to bring that
down to to a sea to bring it down to a
sea was going to cost a lot of landlords
thousands of pounds getting solar panel
windows and stuff and a lot of landlords
sold and then they recently just said
we're not going to do that anymore
everything's just going to be the same
is it just me that thinks maybe that was
a plot was that a plot to get the
average amateur landlord to sell their
house because they ultimately want us to
own nothing and them to control
everything let me tell you what if you
own property it's very difficult for
them to get property off you the media
are saying oh house prices are dropping
now's a bad time to invest your property
sell uh no now is a buyer's market a
buyer's market market is when it's a
good time to buy let me tell what a
buyer Market is buyer market is when
house prices are low and there's not
that many people that are looking to buy
but there's loads of houses so you can
just have your pick and after a crash
will come a boom and also rents are an
all-time high an alltime High the
average rent last month by the BBC was
announced that the average rent not in
London London is thousands of p a month
across the whole of the country the
average R is £950 okay very soon we'll
be over £1,000 a month so rents are an
all-time high and house prices are going
down which means that your yield is
higher and people are say oh but
interest rates have gone up well for a
start interest rates aren't high right
now if you're getting a a buy toet
mortgage you might pay round about 5%
for your interest rates which means that
if you got 100 Grand mortgage you're
going to pay five grand a year five
grand a year is not very much if you're
renting your property out smart as an
investor the five grand is going to be
covered and you're going to have way
more left over if you can't make it
stack up with mortgage r at 5% you suck
and should never be an investor because
interest rates aren't that high they are
higher than they were but they're not
that high and I think very confident
that interest rates will come down how
do I know that catch this this is really
important a couple years ago if you got
a mortgage the longer you fixed the term
of the mortgage for the longer you fixed
the rate so when interest rates were low
if you said I want to fix that low rate
please for 5 years you know what
happened they say okay if you want to
fix it for 5 years it's going to be a
bit more more why would they do that
because they knew that rates were going
to go up but now most lenders if you
want to fix the turn long it's cheaper
why well the only explanation is because
the lenders know that rates are going to
come down and when rates come down then
everyone's going to want to start buying
again and then we're going to into to a
boom don't wait for that don't wait to
buy property buy property and wait
what's going to happen with the
government well labor are going to get
in I'd put a lot of money on that and
you might think that's a bad thing maybe
you think oh I don't want labor to come
in conservative have been pretty bad for
landlords I actually once I want labor
to get in I'll make money whatever
happens but if labor are saying that
when they get in cuz they will when
labor get in they're saying they're not
saying what you think they might be
saying you might think they're going to
say oh they're going to punish landlords
and punish rich people because they hate
Rich no no no no they're not saying that
labor are saying that when they get in
they're going to make it really easy for
developers all of the lands that we
currently can't build on loads of
Brownfield sites green belt land they're
going to undo it which is going to mean
it's going to be easier to be a property
developer they're going to LAX the
planning policies and the planning laws
meaning that it's easier to get planning
permission which I mean on a personal
level I'm ridiculously excited about
because I have a lot of land and I've
been trying to get planning permission
on some of my land for like two three
years and can't so that's potentially
going to massively help developers and
I'm a developer and you should be too
and I'm a property investor and I think
you should be too they can't take
property away from you why do you think
the rich people want to incentivize you
to sell your house by scaring you
because then when you sell your house
the elites and the rich people are going
to come in buy the house and then
they'll rent it back to you in this
market right now before we go into 2024
educate yourself on how to get
properties make the most of what's going
on in the market right now make the most
of the fact that we're in a buyer Market
buy low rent high with a property
manager nearby why so it's passive and
if you haven't got the money to buy a
house you haven't got the money to
invest in property then go get the money
and even if it's not your money even if
you have to find such a banging deal
that it's attractive for an investor to
come on in bring the investor in but
make sure that the property is at least
partly in your name you can look back
over the last 100 years and you can see
when were the best times to buy the best
times to buy are just after or during a
crash because after a crash comes a boom
why is everyone worried in a buyer
Market that's when you should be getting
the bangers and I'm telling this to the
average person the rich people already
know this the rich people are already
doing this 100 years ago the average
house in 1920 was £500 do you think that
in 1920 they said oh in 10 years time
it's going to be £1,000 to buy a house
the people would have laughed at them
£1,000 for a house no one would pay that
10 years later 1930 people paying £1,000
then 10 years later £2,000 look back it
looks like nothing and in the same way
way in a 100 years we'll look back and
we'll say 300 grand for a house it will
seem like peanuts because what's
happening is the government are printing
so much money through the bank of
England that money is becoming worth
less I've seen this happen over the just
just in my time of being a property
investor like now if you've got 30 grand
now it doesn't seem that much 30 grand
oh it can barely be a deposit on a house
but 15 years ago if you had 30 grand
that was a lot of money you could
potentially buy two houses with 30 grand
because as they print more money money
becomes worth less so as they're
printing more and more money what's that
doing to house prices where it's pushing
house prices up that's why they put
interest rates up just a little bit to
try and balance it out a little bit so
get educated buy properties bring people
in don't be scared when you read stupid
headlines about what they're going to do
because until it's law they've not done
it yet make hay while the sun shines and
own assets that you can keep that you
can cash flow from and you can sit on to
pass generational wealth that also
produce you passive income that mean you
don't have to be a slave working 40
hours a week for 40 years to then retire
on 40% of what you couldn't afford to
live on in the first place if you want
to spend a day with me well I'm going to
show you exactly what I'm buying I'll
show you how to negotiate deals how to
speak to agents how to use other
people's money you come to the property
Investor's crash course fine deals maybe
I'll even fund them for you who knows
I've got my own bank now Samuel leads
Finance the sole purpose of is to
finance my students deals so you want to
get in on that you have to book on to
the property investors crash course
spend a day with me link in description
get booked now tickets are £1 I'll see
you
[Music]
there